hello everybody welcome to part six of
my resident evil village playthrough
where we
devastatingly just killed the love of my
life um so i'm not even sure if i really
want to keep going but here we are
and uh i
i mean i was in that i was in that
castle to try to find
my stupid daughter uh for some reason
um but did maybe
it seems like the brightness actually
improved maybe that was an update hang
on i'm gonna
do that maybe that'll be better now
just turn the brightness back to normal
um in any case
it's still really dark it's fine um
yeah not entirely sure what i'm supposed
to be doing now that's where we just
came from
that'll loop back around eventually did
i get everything here yeah all right
that's gonna be a thing we shoot
so yeah she was uh baby was not in the
castle
maybe baby's in this cave babies love
caves
but yeah not sure where i'm headed now
probably back to the village oh
i imagine
are these fish gonna attack me also i'm
totally turning the brightness back up
there we go it looks washed out but
maybe there'll be a patch eventually
um i'm playing on xbox series s sorry x
and uh it seems like a lot of people are
having the same problem
when you know i played with all of my
settings but i just can't seem to get
this game to look
together the way it should
imagine i think this is actually just
that friendly witch lady
who i'm not at all afraid of um which
having said that probably means i'm
about to be mauled by her
but for now she's really my only friend
she's
she's cool she's got like sort of goth
hippie vibes
in life and in death glory to mother
miranda
totally yeah
got that ethan audiobug again
almost did that's a question for the why
sick burn yeah sometimes uh you can't
hear
ethan speak that is also a bug
i don't mind it makes him a silent
protagonist almost
too late nice the child is a throwback
life for life
i'm honestly not even that upset so the
four bloodlines
may open the path you seek
i'm not out here trying to be a single
dad it's fine
[Laughter]
see if this will fix the audio
oh no um now i can't get through that um
uh wooden door
whatever will i do okay that did seem to
fix the audio
okay so we've already done this then
we've got
house
heisenberg and morale wait
no i don't think the symbols really mean
anything heisenberg i think is the
guy who's like thor oh
good man if i do she clearly planted
that there for me you get what i'm
saying
she's my only friend okay and she is a
good friend she's trying to hide it
because yeah she's got you know those
goth vibes she's really got gotta stick
to
but i think we both know
okay what uh
absolute [ __ ] show am i walking to now
can't wait see the last time i found a
door like this with a thing to just
conveniently pull down that's when thor
man showed up
hands just looking great just wow
move over wolverine ethan winters is
here
everybody's favorite
this is a little bit ominous to me
did fix the audio good stuff um oh this
is where they're gonna
kill my baby oh i recognize that symbol
should put this dirty flask on here
it sure does i don't imagine there's
anything
what if we just put the family photo on
there no one day
we'll get to use that stupid family
photo
all right
keep rolling it wants me to be here
i just i disagree i don't think i can
interact with this yet i gotta go find
my baby and bring her here
no no not yet not yet
going out just in case why don't we do
some crafting actually
um i'll do
[Music]
cool
options huh let's go this way
okay i've chose correctly
all right
what is what is this this
why is it all stringy on the bottom
hello
are you taking a nap it's just a very
large cocoon
oh god oh my that's a lycan right there
huh
i've still not actually figured out how
to deal with them
which i hadn't considered until now
i probably am equipped enough to kill
them
at this point where i wasn't when i last
encountered them
a boat oh that's the drawbridge okay
um
but same token
they're very fast
two shotgun shots looks like it
we can [ __ ] with that oh well unless we
do that
and one more to the left and that's it
but
they do really [ __ ] stand on rooftops
huh
which buddy hey you missing the body
you dropped your light come on uh oh
oh my okay i really ruined that man's
life
um okay who's that who the [ __ ] is that
who's that is that just you dying or is
that somebody new what do you mean
you're not good
who do you think you are
where do you get off um
oh this is that place that i i've been
to
maybe we got a load of drumroll first
i will take the camp fluid i will see if
there's anything around here
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh am i missing that
badly there we go there we go
get dead mother miranda
and then lower this oh i need a thing
it requires a thing i hate it when it
requires some other kind of item
damn okay
i guess we're just gonna
okay hey hello hello hello hello
[ __ ] off should i have waited for the
room to get back up for killing purposes
what's that what's that what's that oh
it's his body fading away
it's gonna make me nervous every time
it's a screen
it's not like bioluminescent mold that's
really bad for your lungs you should
somebody should come through and check
that out that
they can kill babies is mia here
is rose here i keep calling
interchangeable names
because uh y'all don't kill my baby with
this
kind of behavior and i'm not here for it
all right just you know be thorough
unnecessary probably a waste of ammo but
whatever i can craft now whatever
whatever whatever
nothing great cool love that for us oh
so were you here the whole time how did
i not even
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yesterday is dead
anybody
i don't believe you i have so many keys
none of these are gonna work surely but
let's just try them all
just in case you know damn
if only i could have predicted that that
would not work
well this is a useless bloody room then
isn't it and i'm not gonna remember to
come back here probably because it's not
marked
okay
great i don't know what
these townspeople were thinking you
really thought that mother miranda would
save you from this
hellish [ __ ] and and you have
statues erected that look like this
i think you were kind of asking for it
like i don't mean to victim blame
but okay
you know what i'm saying who are you
[ __ ] kidding
there you are i had a feeling you would
pop up here
it was all worthless is that so
i assume you've picked up something of
value
not sure if it's a value but
why you have your daughter right in your
own hands
what what are you saying
take a closer look
oh no oh my
this did i finish the game is that it
ox head
rosemary
[Music]
babies who knows roses don't say another
word
this this is impossible this just can't
be
your daughter's essence is still intact
her powers are truly unique
oh who couldn't even do this rejection
skipped something something something
from this yeah beheadings
come back from me it's a house with a
red chimney on the western side of the
village
go and seek out the man who lives there
then we can continue
our conversation okay we're holding out
and get to the damn point you don't have
to trust my word
so i was gonna say but do you have any
better options
i don't know if you should be rude to
the jew ethan i really hope you don't
have to fight him i like him
your choice the customer is always right
is it going to start like pulsating like
is this
a way to just rip off death stranded
capcom find out this is a lie
[ __ ] joker i don't appreciate this ethan
i really like this dude i don't [ __ ]
with this
behavior um
i mean i wonder maybe oh oh this is what
we're gonna have to do we are gonna have
to put the head in here
oh my god that's
[ __ ] up
what the hell that was probably mother
miranda
and she looked hot which as far as i'm
concerned is a huge win
there are hot chicks left
yeah oh
i don't know what else i'm going to do
with it as much as i don't want to sell
it
yes beautiful
even in death that waistline yes
my man that's expensive
but i am going to want it i don't care
about the pipeline so much what is this
magnification scope rifle cheek wrist
huh
that actually would be very handy
because that was the issue that i had
with the sniper rifle
but now we're going to do that
congratulations with this you'll not
worry about
missing anything and then do an upgrade
on here
sure leave this to me
and that should be right this is more
important good day then well now
look at all this inventory space my god
i don't even need it um okay so i'm
looking for
maybe i go this way that's where i'm
supposed to go this way
okay cool
what oh
i mean these look like four winged
whatevers but
i guess i can't go that way um
that's weird
that one needs like a fetus inside of
the four winged key
of course yeah whoever designed this
town again
don't mean a victim blame but
you know i don't know what you [ __ ]
expected okay
um all right okay this is just really
just follow the path left
very significant while
and we should be okay right right right
i don't want to go in here though
because i missed something
what have you for me house
what have i missed
let me make you blue please
oh well that's a shame it's probably
going to be that
and i am out of luck picks this time
right i've not made a mistake
we do not have lockpicks
see okay again
who decided whose brilliant idea was
that poem okay i don't know
what you [ __ ] pounce people expected
all right and [ __ ] like that and even it
out
just really trying to die
okay not as simple as i thought
go this way and then through that house
oh okay i have that now okay yeah that's
it so we go back up
to the left
[Music]
oh i cannot
okay in which case we are going to have
to go through that way
all fully around here and then up it is
[ __ ] i also can't go there because of
that
how to navigate uh is this
still locked
it is
somewhere from here no okay um so that's
locked that's locked
we can't get through here cause
something's crashed we can't get through
here because something's crashed
where in the [ __ ] what does this require
four winged unborn key jesus okay
um was i supposed to take the boat
no i don't have the crank i can't do
that yet
like if i could get there is there a way
to get through
any of this stuff maybe back through
this way and then [ __ ] around out
here
well we can go back to the church anyway
because it's red
oh hello good to see you
glad all my friends came out to meet me
when i came back here it really means a
lot
was this here before what
somebody's looking for
search laboratory analyze mold samples
infiltrate factory it sure is a resident
evil game ladies and gentlemen
[Laughter]
um we do have other things in here for
me huh
i miss you so much i'm so sorry just
please forgive me for what i've done
that i okay oh there it is
i'm a little bit mad at whoever thought
these crystal fragments were a good idea
i will say that much
i'm a little bit upset
i also should be making more saves i
wish that i hadn't made a save
in uh in the castle okay so i can go
here now
so why not
maybe i am just supposed to be looking
for this other key
oh it's because i picked that it's cause
i picked the wrong one it's not
thank you
okay anything just a chicken
perhaps no that's something other than a
chicken
maybe it maybe they're just very thick
chickens deceptively thick
thicker than you would think they are
a big crystal huh all right what might
we do
doesn't seem oh yes huh good yes yes
good good good good
it doesn't seem to be anything else here
yeah we gotta go find that six winged
unborn key huh
you do not love to see it just realize i
lost a chunk of my recording there but
uh
we shot a goat on the top of the house
and killed some chickens
um and also
[Music]
i got a crystal shard from that that's
it though
so i'm thinking i need to go through
here
and then to here it's gotta be that if
this is blocked
surely there's some way through go in
this house first
i touched the door and it still scared
the [ __ ] out of me
i heard a scream from the house with the
chimney that's what i'm trying to go
going to take a look but it was blocked
by debris going on
to have to take a long way around who
would have thought the hole in the
stable walls
great okay i really appreciate that
thank you
there is stuff in here for me to find
and i will find it down here this is my
whole mo
this game not even scary we're worried
about this piece of cake
okay
nice little futon you got there yeah
what the [ __ ] was that
all right anybody
anybody out here
i'm trying to be friends
this is probably the stables is this the
thing i can unlock while i'm here it is
okay
okay
oh my god
really [ __ ] that shut up
maybe i didn't maybe i did hit him but i
didn't even realize
let me just [ __ ] take a look in here
oh hello apologies that was very rude of
me sir i'm sure you're very embarrassed
embarrassing for both of us
um okay so then we're gonna go
is sort of around here that seems like
it's probably blocked
i remember this area yeah [ __ ] this
place
that's a lot of sounds is that big guy
gonna come back
let me move this somehow interesting i'm
gonna need
a jack of some kind um yeah the big
wolverine looking guy is he around
that's locked of course it is video game
hates me
this well i can open this now
which is what a whole new area i don't
know if i want to do that yet
do i this probably is going to be the
way to go um
there's something here that i hadn't
explored yet
that's the cage sound
there we go so anytime you hear a
swinging cage
give me one of these gave me so much
money last time
i think that's it probably there's not
much else going on in here
[ __ ] are all these sounds dude
this game is the worst man
okay hello
probably gonna find some way to move the
tractor out here maybe
anybody anybody
oh my
i don't love that
which window man which
which window i don't want to do it
anyway i really don't want to do it i
don't i don't want to do it
okay 0804
that was just mean that was that was
really [ __ ] mean
okay zero seven zero eight zero four
probably [ __ ] hell i like i think i
hurt myself with how hard i just chopped
yeah i already forgot it zero
seven zero four zero eight i think it's
gonna be zero seven zero four eight
seven zero
four might i go that way
four zero eight
jesus okay cool
cool cool cool ah that's what we've been
looking for
all right uh that's everything here
where are you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh oh
you're everywhere oh great oh
cool this oh there's three
actually you are we
just gonna hang out like is this sort of
some kind of
fun time standoff for the whole family
or what
like just come at me then just do it
just do it stop
[ __ ] around do it
i am a lot better off here and that was
i think i'm spraying them
what did i know oh my god
it's fine oh my heart rate just then
wow okay all right i kind of want to
save
if i'm being honest i would love to
go save somewhere actually
all right anybody on any rooftops
no okay cool
jacket
all right neat let's go i just
it's not necessary or like maybe it's
not necessary
did you think about that at all what the
[ __ ]
what what the what how are they so
stealthy you know
how in the [ __ ] are they pulling this
[ __ ] off
i should be conserving ammo yeah i
thought it might tell me that
i'm gonna get myself in trouble soon you
sir should be dead 10 times over what
the hell
okay how's the situation looking now
come back around this way
keep going
okay i should remember to use the pipe
bombs
okay oh well i can unlock this gate oh
[ __ ] off
every time i get an idea that
something's gonna go in my favor the
game's like why don't you go [ __ ]
yourself
on the top of this roof of course
ah [ __ ] me
just you then at least they pick up the
stuff that i need to craft things to
kill them
that's not the it's not the worst
still not going great i need to stop i
need to stop
okay we're gonna go
what
oh my god who well
oh my god no no no no no no no i was
trying to throw my pipe bomb
how do you like that not much turns out
oh my god he's fine
he's absolutely fine
are you some kind of god
dude
no that's got to be it
holy [ __ ] i need to start being more
stealthy out here
i appreciate that though that's actually
great for me
jesus
okay this is what we're trying to open
oh it's the iron key every time i want
every time
okay
why did i unlock it what is the purpose
of this
ariel who and who was that big guy
man you know i just everybody's
oh oh sweet like now i can
get stuff from the wells
i don't feel good about any of it
uh i'm still trying to get there
um but i feel like i should take out the
paltry
as a thing that i have just now learned
that is a good idea
get back here you [ __ ]
you sneaky the hardest enemy in the game
[ __ ] how am i not hit you ethan okay i
don't feel like this is my fault i just
don't
you know don't be like it don't be like
him
great okay take out the other chickens
and retire to enjoy my life
as a paltry farmer have we been in here
negative
not having the um comfort
of the shotgun makes me a lot more of a
coward than i was
i was like i'm not afraid of anything
i pressed the wrong thing on the d-pad
every time too
um okay oh i've already been here i just
unlocked that
so oh that's the red chimney
oh great that's exactly the kind of
thing i'm after
okay concerned about this but
let's do it do exactly as i'm told
i'm not sure why i was sent here
being honest i don't love it for me
okay
[ __ ]
yeah yeah no they are hard to kill
without
unusual bits and pieces
what is all the sound outside um
sacrifice two goes to mother oriental
let's chill
i could well the mother miranda the
messages from mother miranda
instructed to take the items to the cave
church at sunrise
cave church all great lords were there
mother miranda was holding a child
um she listed something and touched the
child i can't explain why the child
turned into a white crystal
then she smiled this is the chosen child
she will return to an original form no
matter what befalls her
can't wait to have to murder my own
child frankly
okay we're looking for key parts
all right yeah i would like to take this
i think or do i have to bring them back
here
no there we go okay
cool better see the duke again bits of
fetus
all right thank you appreciate that
okay before we go back to the duke
i'm going to go for all the wells
so i know they're all done that's what
we're going to do so
let's make it happen and i don't think
there are any
bad boys left but i'm not positive so
this one's up
across the fallon plot
oh the gargoyles are back what the [ __ ]
i didn't know you'd be back those aren't
all goggles i don't know those are birds
these are got glass
those are the roof boys it's just oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna have to shoot the mono
oh do i kill them with one shot i don't
know if he died
stop stop moving you can't
get away from me weird tongue dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
he's completely missed [ __ ] you
you're too close i should really just
change weapons i'm gonna do this
and then we're gonna oh god
this is my old shotgun i mean a handgun
i i don't know why he's making me so
nervous he's just too sporadic
you're too sporadic i don't like it are
you dead no
[ __ ]
that's gotta be it
oh my god
stay down okay i need to i really messed
that up that was real bad it was a bad
time
i think crystal wing that's neat um
we want to shortcut this for now
i don't know if that was the right call
to make at this stage
but we'll see we'll try it out and then
i'm just gonna shortcut
the sniper rifle while the shotgun is
out of ammo
just for the fun of it okay
i did it fat i did i did bad all of that
was quite bad
we're going to find this
well [ __ ] god oh my god for some reason
this part
during the day i'm getting like sick to
my stomach from how hot i'm jumping at
this [ __ ]
this shouldn't be that scary
oh there's a bird cage there i know how
to get this now look at me dude
all right you [ __ ] [ __ ] leave me
the [ __ ]
alone jesus christ
it'd be tight if you had a lockpick in
you no just lay
wait where did it fall oh my god why did
it fall oh my god i'm video game
no no there you go
uh the well this other side of this
house
oh oh
you always expect that don't mind if i
do
no here we go do i have to kill this pig
as well
is he gonna get mad at me i'm sorry
buddy
i'm very sorry
i'm really sorry i don't want to do any
of this why are you this strong
[ __ ] out i'm trying to make it quick
okay i was starting to wonder if maybe
he couldn't be killed and then i had
made a terrible mistake
quality meat i have no idea what i'm
supposed to be doing with all this meat
um okay we're going to put the well
wheel
in here
maybe i could use some we will take pipe
bombs
not quite what i was after but we'll
take it
so that's done this is all done
i doubt that can even be explored
well down here how did i get to that one
[ __ ]
we're trying to get to that well right
there which does require going
this way i feel like the brightness is
looking good right now though
i will say that we're happy about the
brightness situation as it currently
stands
okay well is here
great oh well
uh didn't i get a body for that
it would be in items nope
okay
yes
is that just to be sold yeah wow okay
why not um
i want to go through that house but i
can't i don't have a lockpick
down [ __ ] i'm forgetting how to [ __ ]
navigate this [ __ ]
here we go well other side
let's go
pretty sure everybody's dead hey
look at it giving me the thing that i
wanted but now that happens
oh i got all the wells i feel good about
this progress
all right let's go into here
i hope no more of those big guys show up
because i i'm
well i did get more pipe bombs but i am
[ __ ] out of shotgun shells right now
um okay
what do you got for me mate
what is this beast
oh is that the horse from this oh this
is the house i was in the very beginning
ah
so oh my god is that what i meant by
beast
[ __ ] hell
uh well that's why we're using our lock
pick
okay i'll take
that's all that done and the stupid
beast
so go back out
and this way out this way
what does it say
i'm just scared myself okay i don't feel
good about this
i feel like maybe something not chill is
going to happen in here
putting that out there
great yeah what was that
just close it okay
there's going to be somebody in here
surely to whom it may concern due to
luthier's long absence i'm keeping hold
of this housekeep please find me if you
need it
joseph simon i don't have his house key
there's nothing i can do about that
right now
we need to find one joseph simon
oh my god panicking he's just a stupid
goat
okay
anything in here now that you throw
[ __ ] pigs at me
i just don't trust this game at all
no that seems okay
i'm looking for a doll's head
all right and that's gonna be that done
we can't get into that yet
okay i think i've cleared as much of
this map as i can
for now looping back around
to the duke
and i've got meat maybe he could do
something with my meat
how was it did you learn anything no no
i found these feathers yes right right i
did my face just like you said you would
settle down first you must use that key
and collect all of your little roses
flasks
where are the rest of them not quite
what i hoped parenthood would be
you have the one and the other lords
have the rest
lords
mother miranda is the cold calculating
ruler of this village
serve under her the first you've already
met
the lady demetrius i miss you baby oh
lives deep in a valley of mist the doll
maker
donna benevianto that's gonna be [ __ ]
up
for sure none of her playmates have ever
come back from that dangled
great very excited can't wait
the third is moreau a being of twisted
flesh that lives in the reservoir past
the windmill
okay cool yeah it is said that he is not
the only monster that lives in those
waters
the fourth and most dangerous is
heisenberg i don't know what to do about
him
in his factory on the village outskirts
i hate a factory project
let's just say parts of the human
imagination are better left alone
okay great
what the [ __ ] what's all this
what a wheel weapon um what the
hell okay
these bits of treasure that i need
okay
interesting if you truly wish to save
your daughter you must first gather the
four
flasks i'll do you a personal favor
i've marked the lord's locations on your
map hmm
some treasures still work in this
village
i'm sure each one will prove of great
use to you
why are you doing all this i am gonna go
get them all i know i
please do come again soon can you tell
me what to do with these meats my dude
you wish to make a purchase ah yes i
have you
can find some quality ingredients and
bring them to me
um is it stuff that i sell
[Music]
hang on did i just miss a crafting it's
literally right here
oh oh my
carry on i can hardly wait
just excuse me a moment cool
like a legend of zelda
apologies for the weight here's your
share
damage taken when guarding decreases
permanently oh
oh nick such a dish could be had i don't
know we have an inter-bound frontier
permanent stuff
do you see game
no i can't make anything else
interesting all right
cool
i used to be alive okay
pocket crystal skull crystal wing
again i want to check if these things
can be combined at all i can hardly wait
for the next ingredients
did you say anything about no i think we
just saw all this
i was just thinking of ways to pass the
time
do that do that do that do that
we're going to need to find a head for
that i still don't want to sell that
it's a token you know it's a monument
all right so all that now this is
something to splurge on
beautiful what do we have in here
right now customer will pop in sniper
rifle reduces weapon swivel aiming
it's expensive high magnification scope
i don't feel like i'm gonna need that
i probably will want that
and i don't feel like i'm gonna need
that urgently either so let's do the
pipe bomb yes i can see why you'd be
interested this one
yes beautiful
what else do we want to do here i feel
like we want to upgrade this
you do all of these i think not quite
oh no i can okay cool leave this to me
okay um
nothing there pay me no mind
all right i feel okay with all of those
choices we just made we meet
and then i'm gonna see if i can open
this i'm not positive though because i
feel like i'm still missing the fetus
bit
yeah um
alright so what do i need to do left in
town
okay so we've saved and i think
i might be able to get this um
but i think that's the only one i can
currently get because if i look at these
that's great i can't get to that yet
that's that locked house from
joseph or whatever that i can't get to
yet that's gonna require me getting over
here how did i get to this house i
honestly don't know
and all of these i really don't is there
still a way that i can do that
ah okay in any case
we're going to go for this treasure box
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh i know you [ __ ] don't waste an
ammo out here
when i get scared it's not great there's
gonna be another one it's gonna be
another one i swear to god
it's just sitting here now
all right necklace
is this going to be an important item it
is that's interesting
hmm
a key
i wonder what i need that for hello oh
thanks oh great oh cool
oh one oh oh my that makes me think that
i should have
i don't think i can get back into
something that uses explosive rounds by
now
and i do not there's only one place that
i know of
it has a key
that i've not
uh that has a lock i mean that i've not
unlocked
so let's go do that okay
so it's like when i first got to that i
wonder if i can open this surely not it
doesn't have fetuses in it
i think i can you know oh i'm pretty
sure i can open that so that's where
we're gonna go
um but we have other things to deal with
first thank you
it was in here
who is this key yeah
just a goblet
okay get me some money that's cool
we will
go down here
put the thingy in here oh
for some reason i was so convinced that
that would be a well wheel
no of course it's not okay never mind
i don't know why i thought that um and i
was like
all the wheels don't know the same stuff
to function in the exact same way
what's the problem they do not turns out
um all right i think that's where we're
gonna go
um which i think we will do next time
i know this is largely town exploration
but we're making it happen
i will sort my inventory and we will
head through
these gates i'm sure it's going to be
great